升息一開始
股市反而開始上漲
因為我們說短期
最大利空出盡了
也就是在年底前
有機會再次
改寫新高點
甚至就挑戰5萬點
大家好 歡迎再次收看
投資的一千零一夜
我是峰哥
升息循環開始了
但最後會升到哪裡
這是現在大家最關心的事
而且對台股的影響
又是什麼
我們今天來討論一下
那我們先從
上週的關鍵場景說起
上週三就9月16號的那一天
聯準會以12比0全票通過
升息1碼
就0.25個百分點
那聯邦基金利率
代表短期利率的水準
就來到3.75%到
4%這個區間
那這個利率水準是
2023年7月以來
整整3年多
第一次升息到這個水準
所以市場在升息前
其實已經
嚇了一跳
因為本來是預期
不升息的
但後來就開始
慢慢對市場
升息的機率愈來愈高
本來是6成
後來到8成
甚至最後到了9成
所以市場在這個
預期升高的情況下
十年期美債的殖利率
也是一路就往上衝
先衝到了5%
後來又到了5.04%
這是19年來的新高
台灣的央行的理監事會議
也做了
這個利率決策會議
但是他們的決定是不跟
重貼現率就維持在2%不變
那我們來看一下台股
在這個事件後
是怎麼樣
台股在9月18號
當天大漲了892點
收在4萬7180點
那外資單日買超近870億元
可以說是最近以來
非常大的一次買超
所以大家的解讀是
利空出盡
但是真的利空出盡了嗎
還是它只是一個
短期的興奮
所以我們今天要回答
三個問題
美國利率這一波
會升到哪裡
那轉折點
也就是說
高原期之後的轉折
向下的時間點
會大概在什麼時候
另外這一波的升息
對股市跟債市
會有什麼影響
最後 我們還
加上一點大家
很多人就忽略掉的變數
就是這一次葉門
胡塞武裝的攻擊
是不是會產生
一些意外的結果
首先我們來看
利率的未來趨勢
那麼利率會升到哪裡
我們要先看點陣圖
這是我們來看美國利率
最重要的一個參考數據
聯準會這次公布新的點陣圖
就是每位參與決策的官員
對未來利率的預測
那我整理如下
我們先來看
目前
在Fed的點陣圖的中位數
大概是在3.875%
那對應到利率的
實際的這個
政策指導區間
就是3.75%到
4%這個區間
就是現在
Fed設定的利率水準
那預計到2026年底
中位數會來到4.1%
也就是對應4%到
4.25%這個區間
那麼2027年底
也是4.1%
所以同樣是
4%到4.25%這個區間
值得注意的是2028年底的
這個中位數
是來到了3.9%
對應3.75%到
4%這個區間
也就是
從2027年底
到2028年底
這一個一年的時間裡面
利率是看向下的
那我們可以看前面
是從
這個3.75%到4%
在這個區間
甚至是不是有可能再往上
再升1碼都有機會的
可是到了2027年底
接到2028年之後
反而是又走向降息的趨勢
那4.1%代表什麼
代表到年底前
還要再升1碼
就是升到4%到
4.25%
那18位官員
有16位認為今年會升
因為今年
剩下2次的會議
其中4位甚至可能
認為會升2次
不過這是比較激進的主張
那主席怎麼看
就主席華許自己本身
沒有交點陣圖
因為不要讓大家知道
他心裡的自己的想法
不過他在記者會上
有把這次的升息形容成
我們移除了一部分
貨幣政策的寬鬆
這個說法就是很巧妙
因為他說的是
移除了寬鬆
所以他不覺得
現在的利率已經很緊
他只是移除了
一部分寬鬆
所以這代表
後面還有一些空間
那市場怎麼看
目前期貨市場的預估
就10月28號的那一次
再升1碼的機率
現在大概是5成多
那到12月的會議
之前的這個升息
就是9成
就是因為有2次會議嘛
就是這2次會議裡面
如果要再升1碼的機率
就大概9成
不過大家不要一聽到升息循環
開始很緊張
因為為什麼
我們上一次的升息循環
是2022年那一次
那一次
大家都形容是暴力升息
因為從2022年到
2023年
一共升息了11次
累積的幅度真的很嚇人
達到525個基點
就是5.25個百分點
把利率從0%
一口氣
就升到了5.25%到
5.50%這個區間
所以那一次造成嚴重的
股債雙殺
如果
從那段時間就開始投資的人
應該印象很深刻
因為債市就尤其是慘烈
不過這一次我們來
根據目前點陣圖判斷
整個升息應該就是2次
最多最多就3次
那每次只會升1碼
所以升息的高點
應該不會超過
4.25%到4.50%
可是會在高點
停留滿長一段時間
升的不多
但等它要降下來的時間
會等很久
就升的不多降得很慢
這是這一次主要的劇本
那我們再看一下
那為什麼聯準會要升息
因為我們大家都知道
川普很不想要你升息
一直叫你不升息
還叫你降息
那為什麼聯準會你
還是要升息
真正的兇手是油價
我們來看8月的CPI
整體的CPI的年增是
3.4%
看起來是很高的
這也是聯準會
緊張的部分
不過你真的去扣掉
食物跟能源的核心CPI
其實只有2.4%
是2021年3月以來的最低
關鍵在這裡
很明顯嘛
就跟能源有關
汽油年漲了27.4%
那燃料油
就年漲了52%
為什麼油這麼貴
因為今年
這個大家知道
今年2月28號
美國跟以色列對伊朗
開戰以來
這個荷莫茲海峽的航運
就嚴重受阻
戰前大概全球有
五分之一的石油
要經過這條海峽
那布蘭特原油
在戰前
大概在70美元上下浮動
結果今年9月中
一度逼近要到了
110美元
那最近就在100到
105美元之間震盪
那核心通膨只有2.4%
已經我們說的是相對
這一段期間以來
比較低的
聯準會為什麼
還是一次要
一定要升
關鍵就是在2021年的教訓
因為當年聯準會說
通膨是暫時性的
就是解封之後的一個
短暫需求嘛
結果沒想到
那個所謂的暫時性
通膨居然衝到了
40年的新高
讓聯準會
不得不慌了手腳
開始動手
而且還瘋狂的
我們前面講的就一個暴力升息
那大家後面
就一直罵到現在
覺得你可以早點升
為什麼不緩緩的升
要搞到後來很集中的升
升到
讓那一次的升息
那麼痛苦
所以這一次
聯準會就怕到了
就是說
聯準會這次怕到就是說
油價
把大家對通膨的預期
拉上去
那就會本來預期通膨
變成是真正的通膨
所以一旦預期
跟現實脫錨
你很難把它控制回來
所以寧願先動手
先把它壓制住
那講到油
我們就一定要提到
本來只有荷莫茲海峽的問題
現在又多了胡塞武裝的問題
因為本來
沙烏地阿拉伯的策略
就是
荷莫茲海峽 走不通
它就靠
一個東西向的輸油管
把這個原油
本來要從東邊
出口的這個石油
輸到沙烏地的西邊
透過紅海這邊的延布港
去出口
這樣就不用
走荷莫茲海峽
那這條管線
設計容量
每天大概是700萬桶
可是到9月開始
情況突然急轉直下
那有幾個狀況
第一個就是胡塞武裝
居然南下搶地盤
因為本來胡塞武裝
控制葉門的部分
就是離這個
曼德海峽
這個出口這邊
還稍微遠一點
那胡塞武裝
南下搶地盤
就搶下了這個
紅海港口的這個摩卡
那就曼德海峽附近的
這個多座島嶼
也被它們控制下來了
那這個曼德海峽
在過去和平時期
大概承載
全球大約12%的貿易量
那第二個是胡塞武裝
現在對曼德海峽控制力
提高之後
對沙烏地的油輪
經過這邊的影響
就會更大了
所以
接下來就造成了
沙烏地的實際的供給
就減少了
那沙烏地
8月的原油產量
目前已經降到了
每天620萬桶
這是今年的新低
那沙烏地阿美這家
國營的石油公司
甚至通知了部分的
歐洲客戶說
下個月可能
沒有原油可以交貨了
所以高盛就評估
布蘭特原油漲破120美元的機率
已經升高
那也有分析師警告
就是如果管線
繼續停擺個好幾週
油價甚至可能
往130美元走
那胡塞武裝的出現
它本來
把一個海峽的問題
變成是兩個海峽的問題
就是整個
在中東這塊地方
兩個重要出口石油的海峽
全部被控制住了
那對通膨 對利率來說
就是一個
很大的尾部風險
我們所謂的尾部風險
是什麼
就是本來在
尾部通常就是機率
發生機率很低
可是如果一旦發生
對現實的衝擊會很大
就是最好不要發生
但發生的話就很難處理
所以我用三個情境
來推估這個狀況
就比較樂觀的情境是
如果管線在8週內修復
那荷莫茲海峽
出現了臨時航道
那布蘭特原油
可能就保持在
80到90美元這個區間
這就是大家現在
稍微可以安心的區間
當然更好
更好一點
是可以回到70美元
那在這種情境下
聯準會的利率趨勢
大概在4%到4.25%
這個區間
應該就會停了
甚至到了2027年下半年
有機會討論要不要降息
持平一點的預測
就是現在這種
兩個海峽的狀況
就僵持住
沒有更壞也沒有更好
那胡塞武裝會持續的打
沙烏地阿拉伯船
那油價就會維持在
95到110美元這個區間
那利率有可能會因為
兩邊海峽的這個衝突
不降溫
就從我們剛才講就是說
本來高機率是會停在
4%到4.25%
就可能再升1碼到
4.25%到4.5%這個區間
然後這個高檔
會一直停留到
2027年的年底
那悲觀一點
就是胡塞
真的攻擊了所有的船隻
讓大家都一起死
那油價就會衝高到
120美元以上
利率
我覺得這裡就很難估了
就是它應該可能會上升到
4.25%到4.5%以上更高了
那到底會高到哪裡
就要看這個油價
最後衝高到哪裡
這個是屬於很難控制的部分
轉折點什麼時候來
你盯三個訊號
那因為根據點陣圖
那官員預測2027年底
這個PCE的通膨
就是個人消費支出
這個通膨
會回到2.3%附近
那2028年
利率才會降到大概3.9%
這個中位數的水準
也就是說
聯準會自己也認為
真正的降息
要到2027年的很後面
甚至2028年的上半年了
那我自己的判斷是這樣
就是說升息的高點
大約是落在
年底的12月那一次
或是明年初的第一次會議
但是
停止升息到
開始向降息
中間應該會滿長的
也就是說
大概至少要經過
2個季度
甚至是3個季度
是最有可能的
那股價會怎麼樣
其實這波升息前
對股價的反應的修正
已經完成了
所以這一波在
升息的時候
緩緩升息的時候
反而股價
不會受到影響
但是
當市場如果開始
大量討論降息的時候
反而是股市大回檔的
風險會提高
因為如果市場
大量討論降息
就代表
這個降息的急迫性
是很高的
也代表了這個時候的經濟
已經不存在過熱
反而是不是經濟
有降溫的風險
所以這時候反而需要
趕快用寬鬆貨幣
來加持這個市場跟經濟
至於這種情境
什麼時候來
投資人注意
訊號一就是
第一個當然油價
就是布蘭特原油
跌回90美元以下
而且要站穩
就是很重要
那第二個就是勞動市場
這是聯準會最重要的指標
就是它升息
也主要是因為覺得失業率很低
現在預估只有4.1%
就業還很強
所以如果失業率
往上走
就代表經濟轉弱了
聯準會對這個
緊縮貨幣就會煞車
那第三個當然就是市場的指標
就是10年期的美債
10年期美債（殖利率）
如果往下去
跌破4.5%
因為10年期美債
有個領先性
它往下去
現在是5%以上
如果往下跌破4.5%
代表利率趨勢
開始轉變
那這個時候
就可能代表
聯準會的這個
利率趨勢也會轉變
那我們來看
那對債市的影響是什麼
長債你就先別急
那短債可以先收息
目前10年期美債殖利率
大概是5%
其實看利率是滿高的
那30年期是在5.3%
那我們先講長天期的
殖利率會這麼高
除了因為升息的影響之外
還有一個重要因素
就是美國因為財政赤字大
發債多
所以投資人
信心會比較弱一點
就要求更高的期限溢酬
也就是說
我要把錢借給你
這麼長時間
你當然要多給我
一點利息
多拿一點
補償
那我們這邊還要解釋
一個觀念就是債券存續期間
你可以把它想像
想像成是
債券價格對利率的
敏感度
比如說有一檔
長天期美債的ETF
它現在計算出來的
平均存續期間
大概是17年
那簡單來看
它的意思就是
你用殖利率每上升
1個百分點
那價格大約會跌17%
就是這個
1個百分點跟
17年這樣的比較
所以存續期愈長
它的價格波動
就會愈大
那至於我們在債市上面
要怎麼反應
第一個當然就短債
就先收息
短天期的美債
或短天期美債ETF
它的殖利率是
跟著這個升息走高
那價格會波動比較小
所以適合當現金短期的停泊區
那長債我覺得原則上是
先不要加碼
因為雖然10年債
5%以上
利率看起來很有吸引力
不過在這個
利率轉折訊號
出現之前
加碼的話
你有時候可能會碰到一種情況
因為市場
如果悲觀預期說
殖利率會維持這麼高
或還甚至往上衝的話
那代表債券的價格
會存在下跌的壓力
因為利率跟債券價格
是反向的
最後我們來談到對股市的影響
台股這一次對升息的反應
當然是很有意思的
就是升息一開始
股市反而開始上漲
因為我們說短期
最大利空出盡了
所以我們有機會看到
台股在這段期間
一直到年底
拉出這一波
主升段的
最後一波延伸行情
也就是在年底前
有機會再次
改寫新高點
甚至就挑戰5萬點
這是有機會的
不過行情應該會用比較
波折的方式
就是比較小碎步的方式前進
畢竟現在市場的量能
是比較小的
那資金的槓桿也受到
比較多的管制
不再像是
大概前半年是
無限狂奔的資金行情
不過也有一件好事
當然就是這一次
台灣央行
維持利率不變
就幫市場留下了
這個資金的火種
讓這個市場的資金
不會過度的緊縮
但現實上我們還是要
理解一件事
儘管資金面還可以
市場的信心也還不錯
但是台股的估值
已經不便宜了
這一點
是一定要認識的
基本上是過去基本面不錯
可以漲的
或者是有後續
想像題材可以漲的
這些股票
大概至少都漲過一輪
甚至漲過好幾輪的都有
所以你接下來選股
真的會愈來愈難
那如果真的不擅長
選股的人
你用ETF或基金
來參與後面的行情
會更安穩一點
以免漲了指數
你自己手上的股票
沒漲還下跌
這種情形
到第四季一定會更明顯
也就是說真正的
會漲的股票可能
數量是愈來愈少的
而不是那種全面性的大漲
最後總結
總結來看
這一次美國升息
是被油價逼出來
一個防禦性的升息
所以終點我們前面剛才講
最多大概就是
4.25%到4.5%
升的不多
但降的可能會很慢
所以對股市的兩個最大提醒
大家留意
胡塞武裝是最大的不確定性
僵持住可能還好
但是如果升高
衝突升高就很危險
第二個是當市場開始大量討論
降息的時候
反而會是這一次股市
最大的轉折風險的開始
以上就是今天的分享
喜歡我們的節目
歡迎幫我們按讚訂閱分享
以及開啟小鈴鐺
謝謝大家